uh how about
this one
it's another player from austria another
three minute game should be interesting
let's go let's go for a car con this
time
the old car account
why are you thinking so long it's i can
think so long because i'm
trying to talk while i'm playing um
okay this seems a bit stupid
what are you doing sir what are you
doing
i understand is you're going to take on
h7 when the pawn back
this just means that you're going to
have lost the bishop pair and
central control and now you haven't lost
the bishop pair but you have lost
central control and
a pawn which is very bad news
a little trick here if um
takes e5 i got knight takes e5
uh followed by um uh yeah rook takes e5
knight e4 and that's a track druk
which means that i win the exchange it's
probably
not any worse than his other options but
still
pretty uh miserable
yeah so the exchange sack is here
um i can take a pawn i usually take
take pawns when i when i can without
obvious punishment
now it should be just an exchange shop
um with a
decent position as well i mean i have
the bishop pair and
i can start potentially kicking
kicking some stuff away
okay let's go a6 this episode is brought
to you by curiositystream a subscription
streaming service that offers you
thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals curiosity
stream is the netflix for nerds the hulu
for history buffs the disney plus for
the scientist in us
get a limited access starting at just
2.99 a month or 1999 year
and for our audience the first 30 days
are completely free
if you sign up at curiositystream.com
chess and use the promo code chess
during the sign up process
yeah knight a3
but normally my hand is itching
to play uh to play b5 here
just to dominate that knight like when
you see such a knight in a3
your hand just wants to dominate it
um
the only worry was knight to f6 um
winning an exchange but i do think then
let's say queen takes f6
on queen takes a8 queen d6 the double
attack on
h2 and um
and a3 is a good start also
knight is in a lot of trouble if bishop
if rook b3 there
then there was um
then there is bishop e6 attacking both
the rook and the queen
um okay i think his only chance is to go
queen e4 here to somewhat limit the
damage
but um still i can just
calmly retreat the bishop like mission
g7
rook b3 only way to protect the knight
and then
uh mitch b6 still was winning winning an
exchange
i already was up an exchange earlier in
the game but
still that felt like um uh like uh
a good operation for me um now she
is losing another exchange here which
um seeing as he sacked the knight means
that he will be looked down
and i am not
somebody who can look into the future i
cannot tell the future
but still i can tell a resignation
coming soon